foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
less than a week away
from the most important vote of your
life
an hour democracy's lifetime
the president of the United States
is going to be speaking at Union Station
apparently tonight and going to be
talking about election deniers hmm I
wonder who he's pointing out it couldn't
be the Maga Terrace that he pointed out
or a month ago and then one of them
showed up at the Speaker of the House
residents bashing her husband's brains
in with a hammer
trying to assassinate him and attempted
murder scheme trying to kidnap her to
course someone
else to be captured by Maga as this
[ __ ] was deluded by Q Anon
this isn't difficult to understand
it isn't hard to know these facts
and this morning we have
the Capitol Police saying we got it all
on film all of it
not only do they have the confession of
the Maga assassin they have it on film
on camera now apparently no one was
watching the closed caption
television the security cams at the time
there was no live
viewing of it but it is recorded so
um likely in the future we will see
that it's exactly what the law
enforcement and the reports from law
enforcement and the indictments have
shown
it's not complicated
now
when you're talking about Maga
Republicans the fascist in the country
who are about to lose to a huge Blue
Wave I have to be quite honest with you
right now I actually believe I'm very
confident
that this country is going to reject
this nonsense
I think that's why President Biden is
going to come out and speak
I don't think he would be making this
speech
if he wasn't and Democrats weren't
confident here
I think he would do it in a different
form in a different way
but his speech worked
about the threat to democracy of Maga
Republicans their branding of it that oh
he's a demon Sent From Hell or some [ __ ]
because he had blue and red lights
behind him
didn't work
Americans didn't buy the [ __ ] and
the reason why they didn't buy the
[ __ ] is because they're tired of the
[ __ ] they're tired of the nonsense
and the lies on the right they're
[ __ ] sick of it
even even [ __ ] Republicans are sick
and tired of these [ __ ] idiots
believing they're so stupid that they
would believe these stupid [ __ ] lies
yeah so Joe Biden is going to take the
opportunity to do it again
and absolutely tie them up in pretzels
here
you remember the speech that he gave
calling Maga Republicans terrorist
and a threat to our democracy
tonight he's gonna call election deniers
a threat to our democracy
an election denying a threat to our
democracy
this all comes on the heels of a federal
judge in Arizona yesterday and we've
talked about the the clean Q Anon
elections USA I believe that's what the
organization's called again I'm very bad
with names so forgive me if I forget
what their official name is but I think
it's clean Q Anon elections USA it's the
Vigilantes that are out in Arizona we've
seen them on camera in Mesa
intimidating people at the polls the
federal judge said yesterday you can't
do that that's [ __ ] intimidation
there there is there is legitimate
watching
there's nothing wrong with the
legitimate watching we have it in all
elections we actually had it in the 2020
election
who to thunk it
where they were watching the the
election workers count the ballots
and tabulate the ballots
this is stuff that happens
but normally they don't show up to watch
people count ballots in full tactical
gear with rifles and Firearms they just
I mean it's not really you know a
dangerous thing to watch someone count a
ballot
it's not a dangerous thing your your
safety is not a threat why the [ __ ] do
you need to be carrying a firearm you
[ __ ] weak frail piece of [ __ ] what
are you scared of you [ __ ] snowflake
you scared of some ballots coming
against you that people vote against
your dumb [ __ ] ass yeah I think
that's what you're scared of
so the judge says yesterday not only not
only can you not have firearms with 250
feet you cannot talk or yell at someone
dropping ballots in a box
that's what the judge said now if the if
the if the person dropping the ballots
in the Box yells out something
then they can yell back or talk back
but talking at you know 75 feet at
watching
but they cannot wear tactical gear or or
have firearms within 250 feet these
boxes
and they have to adhere to the 75-foot
rule the other thing that's very
interesting and I'll show it to you
later on in the show something that's
very interesting is they're making the
um
uh Melody Jennings we've shown the video
here on of her on Trader TV
over on Steve bannon's
Network
uh and and we watched her story progress
in the clips with Steve Bannon
you know the last clip was she was real
tough and they were gonna fight this and
blah blah blah well now we know what the
fight was about
the fight was is that the judge is going
to make them is going to shut it down
shut down the intimidation my guess is
is that the judge suspects that their
motives and their intent is to
intimidate that's what I suspect
but they have to post something on their
website
they're forced to post something on
their website which is hilarious but the
the thing that's even funnier
is Melody Melody Jennings the the
spokesperson or head or whatever the
[ __ ] she is of clean q and on elections
USA
she has to post it on her true Social
account
it's [ __ ] hilarious
and the funniest part about it all is
the handle that her true Social account
uses the fake name the tandle you know
like you got a handle on Twitter they
got handles over there on fraud social
too
her handle is at Trumper Mel I'm not
making that [ __ ] up
on true social her [ __ ] handle is
Trumper Mel I wonder what their
motivations could be I just I mean I
couldn't [ __ ] figure out by her
handle on true social the official
account by the way
that's what the judge is ordering that
the official count of clean Q Anon
elections USA over on true social the
handle at Trumper Mel I'm not making
this [ __ ] up I'm gonna show it to you
I wouldn't [ __ ] you you are my favorite
turds
listen this is all [ __ ] weird
and everyone's wondering why why am I
talking still talking about this voter
intimidation
because it's coming from Trump it's
coming from Bannon and it's directed at
Arizona they want Carrie late to win
that's what they want they the race they
want more than anything else is Carey
Lake
that's what they want that's the one
they want
they want Carrie Lake to be the governor
so that she could keep pounding away at
this idea that brown people bad and
elections get stolen by democrats that's
literally what they want
they have moved on from Ron DeSantis
folks they have moved on from Ron
DeSantis
Ron DeSantis failed them a long time ago
when he did a shitty impression of trump
and when he's trying to steal Trump's
mantle
and not kiss Trump's feet carry Lake oh
boy she's a [ __ ] boot licker like a
[ __ ] I don't know if you
listened to two seconds of of her
talking but that's all she does is lick
the [ __ ] Cheeto dust off his boots
but it seems really fishy to me really
fishy something smells like fish
when you have the the poll Watchers
these Intimidators is what they are
out in Arizona watching these boxes with
guns with Firearms trying to intimidate
people
and you have you you have Kerry Lake the
biggest election denier of the election
deniers on the ballot
and Steve Bannon shows up
to stump for Kerry Lake it seems kind of
funny
I don't know I'm just saying this all
seems kind of weird
I'm not saying it has anything to do
with each other I'm just pointing out
the [ __ ] facts
I mean I guess maybe we'll figure out if
it has something to do with it I don't
know
do you think it does
let's play Let's play this game for a
little bit do you why why why would
Kerry Lake the election denier
why would she have Steve Bannon
common and endorse her on stage why
would she why would she do that
why would Steve Bannon why would he have
an organization who was just ordered by
a judge to stand 250 feet away from drop
boxes
is this intimidation
hmm
does that sound kind of familiar
it's always projection with these
[ __ ] always you count on it
[ __ ] count on it
and Steve Bannon having Trumper Mel and
that's what I'm going to refer to her as
from now on Trumper Mel
that's her motivation her motivation is
not to have integrity in elections her
motivation is to install people that
will install Trump
that's their motivation and the reason
why is because Steve Bannon needs a
pardon
Steve Bannon needs a pardon
he needs another one another one sorry I
don't want to get the fact skewed he
needs another one
and he'll probably need more of them
because it's coming
and they see Carrie Lake as the governor
of Arizona as their best chance they've
lost the house folks
yeah I know I know the media keeps
telling you and and pundits keep telling
you that Republicans are going to take
the house they're not going to take the
house
they're not going to take the Senate
that's all [ __ ]
that's all [ __ ] they're trying to
trick you into believing that
Republicans have already won
that's all they're trying to do
don't believe a goddamn word about polls
not a [ __ ] word the only time you
should believe it if it motivates you to
vote that's it if it motivates you to
vote go yeah sure believe that poll and
then go vote
that's what you should do but otherwise
[ __ ] those polls they're [ __ ] wrong
they're even they're even affecting the
aggregate
by running right-wing Republican polls
the evidence has been shown already that
they're trying to affect the aggregate
because the whole point is to deny the
election that's the whole point and they
feel like Kerry lake has the best
[ __ ] chance in Arizona to be a
governor
and with with the power of a
governorship in a state like Arizona a
real border state not Florida
Ronda Santos in Florida has tried this
border [ __ ] and it doesn't it's not
[ __ ] working because people in
Florida like what the border of Georgia
[ __ ] are you talking about border
it's not it's not working didn't work
out well with his [ __ ] potential
crimes
and and going to Texas to a border state
to use taxpayers money
to traffic humans migrants to another
[ __ ] state
didn't work out so well
so now they moved on
to the next Trumper Kerry Lake
I'm telling you that's what it is
and if we think if we sit here and
believe that this [ __ ] clean
elections Q Anon USA [ __ ] with this
Trumper Mel individual
doesn't have anything to do with Bannon
and Kerry Lake you are [ __ ] fooling
yourself
like when we heard the report that some
dude broke a window broke into Paul
Pelosi's house and bashed him in the
head with a hammer asking where Nancy
was
because he was gonna kidnap her like we
didn't know that they were some kind of
Q Anon manga terrorist
not hard it's not it's not hard these
are not hard things
to come to grips with now
Carrie Lake Donald Trump Steve Bannon
the left
excuse me the right
the left dude [ __ ] it
the right wing in this country
have absolutely bought in
to every single piece of misinformation
and they have to
they are forced to folks how in the [ __ ]
are they going to run without this is
the reason everyone's asking a question
why are they still making fun of Paul
Pelosi why are they still making making
light of a situation where a speaker of
the house could have been killed because
it's their only choice
what else are they gonna run on
what else are they gonna [ __ ] run on
what are they going to show us their
fake badges
that's a policy we should really get
behind what
they're fake cops oh yeah okay great
great policy we should get behind
what about the one in Pennsylvania where
where crew today is too expensive we'll
get behind that policy too oh yeah okay
or what about JD Vance who thinks this
guy from Canada
the problem is is that he's an illegal
from Canada he was here on a legal visa
and he stayed here this is the [ __ ] they
do this is the numbers that they skew
and they're letting it right out in the
open because that's that's the great
policy we should have
what policy what issue are you going to
vote for Republicans on other than these
[ __ ] trumped-up sons of [ __ ] in
this country want violence
they wanted that guy to go kill Pelosi
hell they're sitting right now
masturbating
to articles that are probably saying
that Paul Pelosi is gonna die
they can't wait for the news
are that another [ __ ] politician
who'll have their head bashed in with
the hammer by a q an honor they can't
wait for it
here's the good news
the good news is is that they them being
a majority is a is a [ __ ] fraud
that's right
the myga Republicans thinking that
there's some kind of majority is a
[ __ ] fraud
it's showing in the numbers folks forget
the polls look at the early voting
numbers the millions and millions of
people who are going to vote
you think those votes are being cast by
a bunch of [ __ ] Maga election deniers
who think that drop in drop drop boxes
are evil
sent here by Satan I'm going to show you
a [ __ ] clip from Mike Lindell the
pillow guy holy [ __ ] I watch this video
I can't make sense of anything he's
saying
like he is so far off the [ __ ] deepen
but that's who they're listening to this
guy this [ __ ] this the the Maga
assassin at the Pelosi's house
they he [ __ ] loved him some Mike
Lindell oh baby
there's nothing better than [ __ ]
voting machine conspiracy theories to
get you all [ __ ] hopped up to go to
someone's house and Bash their head in
with a hammer ooh baby
talk about a good time
that's why they're [ __ ] that's I mean
the question of why Maga Republicans and
why these politicians are still
making light of of the speaker of the
house trying to be the attempt
assassination of the speaker of the
house and attempted murder of her
husband
why they're making light of it because
they're [ __ ] terrorists
they're [ __ ] they're traitors what
more do you want they [ __ ] said it in
Texas at CPAC they said we are all
domestic terrorists they they said it
out loud into a microphone and put it up
on a Jumbotron
listen to them when they're telling you
this [ __ ]
listen
what else you want me to do
and it's a very good sign that the
president United States decides that his
Maga Republican attack because it worked
folks it's worked
it worked
it could expose them for who they are
he's going to expose them tonight
probably for being election deniers and
they're going to ramble on and on and on
and drive the country to go these people
are [ __ ] nuts
they're [ __ ] crazy
because I don't know if your Uncle Earl
who has 15 Trump flags and 35 Trump
stickers on his truck where's a trump
camouflage hat
drinks out of a trump coffee cup
he prays to Trump every night I don't
think that this speech from Biden is
going to change his mind but I will tell
you maybe two or three people that your
Uncle Earl works with maybe they hear
this thing and they go you know that
that I know a guy who is exactly what
the [ __ ] he's talking and he's a nut job
this guy's a [ __ ] nut bag
or maybe maybe it's just that Uncle Earl
has several dozen people who watch his
Facebook feed and go whoa [ __ ] that's
what they're talking about
that's what we have to do folks we have
to expose these [ __ ] we can't
sit quietly by
and just let them do what they want to
do [ __ ] that [ __ ]
we have to expose them we have to give
them daylight we have to show you what
the [ __ ] they're doing and how they're
doing it
and that's what happened with the clean
Q Anon elections USA Trumper Mel lady
I'm dead serious her [ __ ] truth
handles Social the the what they deem as
the official truth social handle for the
clean elections USA organization is
literally at
at Trumper Mel
she's a [ __ ] Trumper she even says
she's self-identified as a Trumper
I ain't making this [ __ ] up
wild [ __ ] it's wild [ __ ] and then this
morning
we have uh a cola the cost of living
um adjustment for the Social Security
but they are literally literally the
White House the White House tweets out
the cola the cost of living adjustment
for Social Security how it went up
number one a lot of these things are
passed into law during inside
legislation to have increases
but they're like oh it wasn't because of
Biden it was because of inflation yeah
you dumb [ __ ] that's what I've
been saying
these right Wingers they really they to
to be self-proclaimed free market
capitalist they really do not know what
free market capitalism is
or how inflation works I've been saying
it I've been saying it for months
haven't I tell me if I'm wrong I've been
saying inflation not bad the thing
that's bad is that your wages aren't
inflating of course the cost of living
adjustment should increase when there's
inflation
wages should go inflate the problem is
you stupid [ __ ] right-wing bastards
is that the corporations not only are
gouging you at the cash register they're
[ __ ] shortchanging you with your
labor
you stupid [ __ ]
the opposite of inflation is recession
now today the FED is going to announce
probably higher higher increase in
interest rates which is which is going
to Tamp down inflation yeah sure but
it's gonna cost the American people
money
how in the [ __ ] can't we get this
straight
what [ __ ] planet have you people been
living on
listen I understand that inflation
causes trouble with the less of of in
the majority of the people but those who
have less it definitely affects them the
most more than anyone
but inflation in general if it if it is
operated correctly in society in a
capitalist system it's not bad
we the people have to force the
corporations
to give us our share of the [ __ ]
inflation
they don't get to keep all the GDP
they don't get to keep the entirety of
the profit that they are gouging from us
we get part of it [ __ ]
and how we haven't recognized that
is beyond me now more and more Americans
are getting wise to this that's why
unions are getting more and more popular
the the just the thought of Union
unionizing is getting more and more
popular
but that's what we have this morning we
have to face this [ __ ] onslaught of
this these [ __ ] lies about elections
and then they don't even know what a
cost of living increase or adjustment as
it's called a cola
they don't even know what it even is
and they're like oh Biden's trying to
take credit for the cost of living
adjustment and so is the security well I
mean he signed it in a [ __ ] bill it's
got his ink on it
and and it's because of inflation that
they gave the increase in in the [ __ ]
paycheck if they inflated it
oh my God it
it's it's tough I know it's tough to
understand these things
for [ __ ] people who don't even
understand
that a goddamn secure drop box at a
county election office is the safest
place to drop your ballot
that that's not the boxes you should be
watching if you're wanting to watch a
box that someone's dropping ballots in
it really makes no [ __ ] sense
it just doesn't
but this is the world that we live in
where
we're going to be charged
for free speech on on Twitter
that's right you're gonna be charged for
free speech on Twitter holy [ __ ]
um I'm not leaving Twitter and I'm not
gonna pay for it either [ __ ] them I
don't have a I don't have a blue chick I
don't really care if Elon would give me
a blue check I wouldn't pay him two
[ __ ] I wouldn't give him a
horsey
I wouldn't give him a horsey for that
[ __ ] blue chick [ __ ] him
um listen you are the best audience in
the world I am so glad to have you here
on hump day on Wednesday uh as we
approach the the next election the 2022
midterms we only have a few days left
remember lean into your democracy engage
in it as I always say find three folks
just three folks that you can encourage
them to vote and they will encourage
three other people once you find those
three people and you have encouraged
them find three more it is super
important right now at this point that
we focus on this election that is it
this election alone and there's a lot of
stuff going on in the world that affects
this election and we should pay
attention to it we should not look away
from the things that are going to affect
this election and you are the best
audience in the world and you are doing
that
you are paying the [ __ ] attention and
you must go vote and while you're out
voting
rather early or next week
stay warm go to
store.thetonymichaels.com get your the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty sweatshirt hoodie
or zip up jacket you can get in a
t-shirt too but stay warm out there
while you're voting go to
store.thedonymichaels.com grab your
Liberty hoodies sweaters and zip up
jackets today
everyone stick around we will be right
back right after these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the Tony Michaels
podcast on Hunt day we are here every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch
simulcasting from the books of face you
can watch us on the Midas touch Facebook
page you can also see us on our Facebook
page happy Tony Michaels so if you're on
Facebook right now or you're looking
you're looking for an alternative to
Twitter I guess go over to Facebook I
don't know I tried to download a couple
of alternative apps holy actual [ __ ] so
here's the thing yesterday we talked a
lot with Texas ball and gave Sanchez
about Twitter and I don't want to talk
too much about it today because we got a
lot of stuff to get to to show you what
the [ __ ] going on out there in the
world but I will say this
I'm not going to say what app it was but
I tried to download it just to grab my
handle right and holy [ __ ] that goddamn
thing took forever to load I finally got
it to work but it was like an hour and a
half just to get my handle holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] crazy I doubt I doubt that thing
is gonna take off anytime soon just
because it's overloaded with users and
and that's what I want to tell you
is that look I understand people are
really freaking out about this social
media thing but don't give up on the
social media that you already have okay
they didn't do it lean into it like
Texas mall said yesterday [ __ ] them they
want to have free speech they want to
open up the floodgates to say whatever
the [ __ ] you want to say well say it and
I know people are freaking out because
they're losing followers and stuff like
that
I don't think this is a big freak out
session about losing followers
I think what we have to do is use social
media to combat misinformation because
it's rampant it's rampant and I'm gonna
show you some of the rampant
misinformation and lies being spread
around today in the [ __ ] list Roundup so
let's surf the Tweety tweets and trendy
Trends let's start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Trends here is the breaking news of the
day when it comes to the January 6th
coup attempt the Cheeto dust kangaroo
coup by the Cheeto dusk q and honor
formerly the Cheeto dust mobster here
you know I used to call them the Cheeto
dust mobster but I think the Cheeto dust
cue in honor really does fit him better
nowadays now Kyle Chaney reports news
we've obtained the eight emails that a
judge ordered John Eastman to turn over
on the January 6th select committee as a
result of the quote crime slash fraud
Dash fraud I guess exception to the
attorney privilege now these were emails
that John Eastman was saying were
protected by attorney client privilege
the judges said no they and he
voluntarily turned these over there was
eight of them and he did not want to
turn over that he wanted back and they
wanted he wanted to race from from the
January 6th select committee's memory
tough [ __ ] January 6th select committee
says no [ __ ] you we're not giving them
back they're ours now you gave them to
us
hey good luck [ __ ]
uh there's just a few problems with it
is that um
they show and this is the political
report you can go look at this link and
go read the the article
the Trump lawyers and the Trump allies
when they were trying to overturn your
election they were trying to subvert
your vote
they were trying to recruit
Clarence Thomas they really thought
Clarence Thomas was their key to
overturning the election seems kind of
funny hmm
again it just you know we're at the
intersection of WrestleMania in real
life and you know in wrestling they have
these story lines right they got these
big [ __ ] story lines that they always
follow
and a big [ __ ] storyline that they
always follow is drama
between you know I don't know allies and
enemies
well here we have the Trump lawyers in
real time in email saying that Clarence
Thomas was their way
of overturning the election they were
focused on Georgia
and giving Georgia legitimate doubt I
don't know maybe it has something to do
with uh 11
784 but I don't know exactly what the
number is
he knew exactly what the number was that
he needed to win uh but it has to do
with Clarence Thomas one spreading
legitimate doubt about the Georgia
election
again spreading doubt
but isn't Clarence Thomas married to
that Q Anon lady that was that was
texting the chief of staff who is
talking to the president about what she
was texting him the Q a conspiracy it
wasn't hey I believe her name is
is it Genie Thomas yes it is
it is
listen if you don't [ __ ] believe
that this is all part of the same
[ __ ] dot to Dot
of a Cheeto desk coup attempt you are a
stupid son of a [ __ ]
that you can't put these things together
that they were trying to make sure that
Clarence Thomas was there was there Ace
in the Hole as Genie Thomas is is
texting Mark Meadows the chief of staff
Q Anon conspiracy theories
come on
come on
just like out in Arizona you think
there's some kind of [ __ ] coincidence
that Steve Bannon shows up to [ __ ]
stump for Carrie late as he's been
interviewing this [ __ ] crazy Trumper
mail lady with clean q a elections USA
that have been intimidating people at
ballot boxes now ordered by a judge to
restrain themselves
you think that's all [ __ ] coincidence
that Kerry lake is the biggest [ __ ]
election denier and that's the race they
want to win they're all in now baby
they're all in on Kerry Lake that's the
one they want now they all the rest of
them Hersch Walker done Dr Oz [ __ ]
done JD Vance done Trump picked him
they're [ __ ] done
they don't want anything to do with
DeSantis anymore
because he's not reliable
Greg Abbott uh you know [ __ ] that guy
they're done with him
they're done with Ron Johnson
Carrie Lake that's the race the real
Maga militants want that's the one they
want
and I'm telling you
why do you think the president United
States is coming out tonight
talking about election denial when Kerry
lake is the biggest election denier that
there is
why do you think that is
hmm
seems Seems sort of hmm I know it all
kind of fits together I guess maybe
maybe it all fits together
in um Maga is Traders they're [ __ ]
Traders speaking of Traders here's
another report uh Hugo has it here
uh speaking of um Traders
um this is the documents case here's
another criminal case that's being
hedged against the Cheeto desk you and
honor uh cash Patel you remember this
character this dumb [ __ ] he went on TV
saying all kinds of crazy ass [ __ ] well
now the Department of Justice really
does want to know what he knows so much
so that they're willing to give him
immunity this is not good for Trump
listen the Department of Justice
prosecutors don't just give
immunity out like it's fentanyl on
Halloween you manga Trump supporters
I want to go over that dude did you know
that there was no fentanyl giving out on
Halloween God damn it
God damn it I was really hoping for this
big surge of fentanyl being being spread
around in Skittles bags like the Liars
said there was going to be there wasn't
one okay
here's the thing
doj does not just grant immunity this is
not a thing they do lightly
not a thing they do lightly
and cash Patel
is is looking for immunity
there's only one reason why cash Patel
would be looking for immunity folks
there's there's only one reason why
someone looks for immunity
not not a lower sentence not something
else because it's bad
it's really [ __ ] bad
this isn't just dude took boxes of
documents
they don't give cash Patel immunity
because cash Patel knows Trump's packed
up some boxes and took it to Mar-A-Lago
nope
you think the doj is going to give this
[ __ ] immunity just to say well
yeah I watched him back him up I watch
them dig in the eye and then he showed
them to me oh
nope not gonna happen
but cash Patel is looking to get
immunity and documents investigation
and what they're trying to do is collect
evidence against the guy who committed
the crime
Trump this is not good for Trump
not good at all
and trust me on this these prosecutors
are not [ __ ] around with this
document's investigation now I know
people are upset like it should be
charged right now and you know blah blah
blah they should be charging Trump
supporters and all this stuff they are
there's that [ __ ] uh court case going
on right now for Trump's business a
criminal investigation there's a
criminal trial going on right now in New
York the other trial that's going on is
Tom Barrack
uh Vicki ward has this report this
afternoon the trial Trump crony Tom
Barrick Drew to dramatic close here's my
report on the inside of the courtroom
today what happened and why all roads
lead to Putin
Tom Barrick and manafort
we're trying to find a back door for
Putin to Trump huh caught seems kind of
funny and the way that you know this
is the UA that let me show you the
[ __ ] picture here
here it is this is the picture they
showed
of the UA UAE president now this is the
government
at Tom Barrick was working with now you
see who he's sitting there with don't
you hmm It All Leads back to one
[ __ ]
Papa Putin they're vladie Daddy
they're murderous dictator
yep
don't get it twisted there is no
coincidences here folks
so as we watch that uh that trial unfold
for Tom Barrick now we'll see so there
are there are trials going on the
Department of Justice is is trying these
people and there's plenty of sentences
and for Maga insurrectionists also
there's another trial going on for
seditious conspiracy I don't know if you
heard that on January 6 apparently there
was a seditious conspiracy to overturn
our election and our government hmm
seems kind of convenient
um yeah the Stewart Rhodes and The Oath
Keepers you heard of that one yep
yep yep the doj is working folks
they're working they're not not doing
something
about this fool
because that's what he is is he's a fool
absolute
[ __ ] fool
speaking of fools
and election deniers
holy [ __ ]
this guy I don't know if he ever stopped
doing crack really
his brain is fried Mike Lindell the my
pillow guy holy [ __ ]
this is Lindell TV the Lindell report
now I don't understand why
um
he's not the the there's the host he's
like the co-host of his own show I don't
know it's really kind of weird
but it's always it's [ __ ] strange but
here he's talking about something I'm
not really sure what this Q Anon word
salad means but let's see if we can
figure out exactly what the old pillow
Nazi is trying to talk about here this
election and I'm telling everyone out
there we are watching from every angle
where there's people in every state
every County every Precinct Brandon
remember you they may think you can't
look and see what's going inside that
black box but we can now in real time
through something called The Edison
report every
um
okay
so he's talking about a black box he's
talking about watching he's talking
about cameras
uh every single Precinct he's gotta he's
got to be talking about this clean
elections USA type [ __ ] right where
they're intimidating people or they're
watching an intimidating election
officials I'm sure
um I don't know maybe this has to do
with him stealing uh machines in
Colorado or he's taught caught up in
this conspiracy and for tampering with
voting machines in Colorado I'm not sure
exactly what he's talking about
but I think what he's saying here in his
crazy little Q Anon mind I don't know if
he read this on gab or telegram or uh
his [ __ ] whatever his social media
thing is
that you can actually tell what balance
are being counted in real time that's
not a thing that's not a thing it's not
a thing they don't they do not count
ballots in real time not a thing nope
they secure the balance for counting but
they do not count in real time
not a [ __ ] thing
again they secure the ballots but no
election officials are counting ballots
yet
Mike it's really [ __ ] weird [ __ ] I
think that's what he's saying it's a lot
of word salad a lot of [ __ ]
but I think that's what he's saying hey
buddy we have cyber guys watching this
we oh even better they have cyber guys
haven't you ever heard of the Cyber guys
holy [ __ ] these are like you know the
old non-cyber guys
they used to wear the ninja costumes I
guess I don't know you know the ones
that would show up at your your polling
place to make sure that you you got a
cast you could cast your mega ballot
they wouldn't let Democrats
cast their meal ballot
oh my God I just you can't even [ __ ]
it's
let's keep continuing it's it's yeah we
got a little bit to go here with the
word salad I looked at a thing today it
was on my my Twitter back from November
of 2020 and they showed CNN 20 000 votes
dropping right off at Donald Trump's
total in real time you guys votes don't
go in reverse
okay so now he's claiming that CNN is
the official counter right
he's claiming here that CNN is an
official counter in real time they lost
are they they counted back votes so
somehow we should not listen to CNN when
it comes to the vote count but in this
instance we should listen to CNN in the
vote count listen when they're doing why
Productions I don't know if uh Mike
Lindell knows much about production TV
but when they're doing light production
sometimes they get Graphics wrong and
then they have to correct them like live
on air so sometimes they get a number
wrong and then they have to kind of
correct it because it's actually an
actual person that is making those
graphics
it was Graphics are made by the Cyber
guys there Mike oh my God these are
computer manipulation algorithms so uh
here's the thing is this selection it's
all eyes we have all the camera angles
now why now everyone would say well Mike
why are you telling the bad guys right
now
okay
um again
when there are cameras inside uh
counting election offices normally the
public like just the public in general
can feed in or can watch those feeds
that's the whole point of the [ __ ]
cameras being there in the first place
for average citizens to check in just to
see Mike
he's acting like they're installing
cameras in all the election offices
which if that's true that's really weird
that we are allowing a my pillow Nazi to
run around the country installing secret
cameras
inside election offices and having
secret information that is live counting
ballots as they go
this is all nonsense it's all [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] lying
but of course maybe he does believe it
maybe he does
well I'm telling him Brandon because the
way I look at it we're gonna it's gonna
be a win-win because the ones where we
can override the algorithms are gonna
why is he so focused on an algorithm
what in the [ __ ] is he talking about
why why is he so focused on that [ __ ]
word algorithm
hmm
listen
people standing in line and going and
casting their vote are taking their bout
to Dropbox and dropping it in a Ballot
Box
there's no algorithm involved in that
that it is literally one person one vote
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
algorithms this guy has lost his [ __ ]
marbles actually I think his marbles
pack their [ __ ] and left [ __ ] this guy
get your [ __ ] Dennis we're getting the
[ __ ] out of here I'll be there they're
gonna win
and then also the ones they don't all of
it we got it all under camera well maybe
this time around the judges and the the
left with the left media and maybe even
the right Media Fox News and Newsmax
will actually report if there's machines
that are involved in this election to
steal another election I I kind of have
my doubts because they didn't report
anything in the primaries when the
primaries do you think Fox News reported
that nice Democrat lady and her husband
that got zero votes in her own Precinct
do you think they reported that Brandon
no do you think do you think hey wait
this guy's name is Brandon do you think
this is the guy that they talk about
when they say let's go Brandon I don't
know
I don't know
whoosh if you if literally and I tweeted
this if you can make sense of any of
that [ __ ] Q Anon word salad if you
really can make any sense of it at all
that is tied to any kind of reality
please message me I really want to know
if Mike Lindell has any of these any
sanity left in his skull
at all at all okay now let's get to the
clean elections you
ow
speaking of [ __ ] voter intimidation
so now let's see where shall I start
here with this um here it is let's start
here
so this story breaks last night
um CBS 5 and 3TV it's uh they're called
Arizona Family AZ family
and they own a couple TV stations
out in Phoenix
um and they're talking about the the
clean elections USA order uh I tweeted
clean Alexis USA is ordered to stop
their Q Anon voter intimidation tactics
at about ballot drop boxes
which include yelling mule and voters
wonder where they got that idea okay
hang on to that thought
these people are yelling mule
at people when they're dropping
ballots and drop boxes okay so here's
the um here's the report of the because
the judge read this restraining order
from the bench
so the judge vocalized the restraining
order
um and then and then actually filed the
restraining order and with court in
court and it was released but this is
the report in a hearing on Tuesday which
was yesterday A Phoenix federal judge
indicated he would issue a temporary
restraining order against a group of
people accused of intimidating voters at
ballot drop boxes across the valley we
know the the the video
from the Dropbox nun who she was dressed
up in a nuns costume who went and uh who
approached and sat next to these
Intimidators these Maga Intimidators
um it says the temporary straining order
says members of clean elections USA
can't intentionally go within 75 feet of
the Dropbox and can't open carry or wear
body armor within 250 feet of the
Dropbox it goes on to say that during
the hearing lasting over five hours
this hearing lasted five hours so it's
not like the judge just took morsels of
information right like little bitty tiny
facts they had a hearing for five
[ __ ] hours
a voter in Mesa said he was intimidated
and called a quote mule by one of those
camped out at The Ballot Box location
I wonder why he was called a mule can
you guys figure that out can you figure
that out for me why would he be called a
meal hmm I wonder I wonder what it could
be really honestly I wonder
I'm just [ __ ] with you I know exactly
what it is I know exactly what it is
okay here is
here's the part of their now I've got
the full restraining order I tweeted it
um let's see who who has it here it's a
Nicole Grigg and I believe she is uh
yeah ABC 15 in Arizona I believe
um she released the entirety of the
restraining order so all of you
questioning rather this screenshot that
I took out of it is real or not I mean
you believe what you want to believe you
can go [ __ ] yourself if you don't
believe it but here it is here's the
screenshot I said here's what clean
elections USA has to post on their Q
Anon true Social account
the account handle is at Trump or Mel
now this is not I I A lot of people are
saying that the Trump or mail account
was suspended on Twitter and I'm not
sure if this is the same person who got
suspended I don't know I couldn't tell
you Trump or Mel on Twitter is the same
Trumper Mel on true social [ __ ] I don't
know couldn't tell you but the handle is
for True social
and I maybe I should have made that
clear I just typed in TS account not
because here's the here's the actual
verbiage on the restraining order
now here's the part where it says what
they have to post
uh number two in the restraining order
defendant Xiao within 24 hours of the
date of this order post the following in
a conspicuous place on clean U.S or
clean elections USA I hate that they
call themselves that it should be clean
Q Anon elections USA we should start a
campaign to get their official name
changed they would probably like it
clean elections USA website and on the
true social page
at Trumper Mel you see it there
and to leave it posted throughout the
closing of election day 2022 so it seems
as if this is the judge's final order in
restraining them and by making them post
this [ __ ] because I think that this
judge believes that they have trained
these people with the intent and the
motive to intimidate here's why number
letter a number eight
I'm all by myself today you guys notice
Gabe Sanchez isn't here today yet
haven't you he's not going to be joining
us today
um he's building he's building more
secret bunkers somewhere and there's a
lot of noise so he won't be able to be
able to join us number eight
under the subheading 2
um quote this is what they have to they
have to quote this on their social media
account and on their website it is not
always illegal to drop multiple ballots
in a Dropbox true I mean I I added the
true it is legal to deposit the ballot
of a family member household member or
person for whom you are the caregiver
here are the rules for ballot drop boxes
by which I ask you to abide
and then they have to proceed that
statement they have to it has to be word
for word
they have to precede that statement by
the preceding statement shall follow by
a copy of the entirety statuary text of
Arizona revised statute
16-1005 or linked there too so they'll
probably just put a link they won't
actually put the description there
why I mean who cares who cares really
the point is is they're making them say
that yes you can legally drop multiple
ballots in the Dropbox like I don't know
a husband can grab him his and his
wife's
um maybe their their college kid that
lives with them uh ballot maybe their
mother lives with them you know they can
go drop those ballots in the Box Jesus
Christ
um number c
letter C and this is this is a good one
this is the best one a copy of this
temporary restraining order or a link to
this temporary restraining order so they
have to put it post a copy of this
entirety of this restraining or a link
to it
um
but here's the thing I'm still trying to
figure out
why why why
why
these people are yelling out mule
you recognize this face don't you this
is Melody Jenkins otherwise known as
Trumper Mel
now I'm not kidding you Trumper Mel you
couldn't it's I
can't make this [ __ ] up folks you cannot
make this [ __ ] up literally literally
the other day on Steve bannon's
[ __ ] show she said we want to
encourage all people to vote Democrats
Republicans blah blah blah [ __ ] blah
here she is with the handle Trump or Mel
and I there this is the reason why they
wanted to post this on this social media
account
literally on her social media account
Trump or Mel this is true social this is
a screenshot that I took I took this
screenshot
from True social
home of Dropbox initiative 2022 look at
the [ __ ] little fingers here pointing
to clean elections USA save our County
save the country save your county save
the country
and then it's got the [ __ ] that
website here clean alexisusa.org so this
is her official clean elections USA true
Social account under the title Trump or
Mel which she's verified look at that
I wonder how much do you I wonder how
much you pay for verification over on
two social you think it's cheaper
than Twitter's gonna be I don't know
just wondering
maybe maybe Elon should check to see how
much they're charging over on true
social you know what the market value is
of a check mark of a verified check mark
I'm just saying because this person is
verified on true social
oh so are you wondering why people are
yelling out mules
um when people are dropping
the ballots at the Dropbox you wanna
know why here's why
here's why
2 000 mules the Dinesh D'Souza
fantasy flick
of how people are dropping multiple
ballots and drop boxes which is a thing
it's legal
again
this
is
why
it's not hard to connect the dots
of what these people are doing and who
they're in bed with
Trump or Mel is on Steve bannon's Trader
TV
they're yelling at the drop boxes at
people mules they're calling people
meals
and she is promoting on the [ __ ] on
the [ __ ] official social media page
which is the title Trumper Mel
it's right there clean Alexis USA She's
Got 2 000 meals in the header I wonder
what it could be I wonder I wonder if
they've told them what to say and what
to yell hmm
seems kind of says seems kind of says
Melody honestly I would welcome you
if you're listening if you're listening
and you want to come on a decent [ __ ]
show that isn't packed full of Traders
come on this show hell I'll I'll I'll
give you a a not so fair shot at
explaining your dumb ass views
and why you think it's okay to
intimidate voters I don't give a [ __ ]
who they are someone in the comments of
these this tweet thread that I put out
with the um
with the restraining order
and the screenshot of her true social
accounts
someone said can you imagine these
people are sitting there and they're
yelling at Maga Republicans who are
dropping their ballots and dropboxes
calling them mules think about them
think about this you cannot make this
[ __ ] up you can't make this [ __ ] up
imagine if you're if you're gonna go
vote imagine I know it's it's it kind of
feels kind of gross to use your
imagination on this one but just think
if you're gonna vote for Blake Masters
and Gary Lake and your wife has voted
for Carrie Lake and Blake Masters and
you decide you know what I'm gonna go
drop these in the Dropbox that way we
make sure these ballots get in
and you go over to the Dropbox and drop
them in and someone's yelling at you
meal meal after you just got done
jerking off to the 2000 meals uh movie
Dinesh d'souza's fake ass movie which
apparently is based on his stupid book
that he's had to retract because there's
defamation they've had to reprint that
son of a [ __ ] because there's
defamation in there's lies provable lies
oh you just I mean and why does this
matter
why does this matter you say
why does this matter because these
people are trying to get Kerry Lake
elected
and there's a there's a reason why they
want Kerry Lake to get elected
there's a reason why
and it's all in in in the aim for
denying elections that is why the
president United States is going to come
out tonight and give a speech from Union
Station
to to rebuke these election deniers like
Kerry Lake because folks they're
focusing in on One race
they're focusing in these fascists are
focusing in because remember how it
happened in 2020 right think about this
and then we're gonna go to a break and
come back we'll talk about some other
subjects here
think about this in 2020 when they when
they started to spread the big lie
they were just looking for one [ __ ]
State just one one state where they
could so doubt just one state where they
could so doubt
just one if they could get just Clarence
Thomas to to just [ __ ] give some
legitimate doubt about Georgia
then they could press the big lie and
they could make a big stink about it
they only need one state folks
they only need one
and it's not going well in Georgia it's
not going well
in Florida it's not going well in Texas
it's not going well in Pennsylvania it's
not going well in Ohio it's not going
well in Wisconsin
it's not going well for them the reason
why these Republicans are freaking out
is because their internal polls are
showing them the real internal polls are
showing not the fake ass [ __ ]
right-wing polls that they're trying to
throw into the aggregate to throw you
off
by believing and the media believing
that somehow there's going to be a
republican Red Wave
they just need one state
and these fascists are zeroing in on One
race and a governor's race is best at
this point to them because they've
already lost the Senate they're not
getting the Senate they're likely to
lose the house at this point with as
many [ __ ] early votes as there has
been the turnout that there has been
they are likely to lose the house
that Republicans they are not going to
win the house
Democrats will be
the majority in the house in the Senate
so what's next on their list they want a
state where a governor
can bang up our democracy and what
better than a border state like Arizona
and what better than a fascist election
denier
and a racist and a bigot like Carey Lake
everyone stick around that we're going
to go over some more subjects
we'll be right back right after these
messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
[Music]
to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
just me today
it's just me the Tony Michaels
D Tony Mingle
Abe Sanchez will be back to join us
tomorrow I promise I mean maybe I don't
know maybe he won't be done with this
deep State bunker
his deep State bunker there's a lot of
noise at his studio so the mic would
catch almost all the noise so it wasn't
going to be very helpful to have him on
the show today because all you would
hear is bang bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang bang because he's
building a you know a deep State bunker
laughs
oh boy oh boy oh uh somebody says here
Mike um on YouTube says I hope 538 and
Nate silver are dead wrong they have
whack numbers
um so this is an interesting um point
that Mike is trying to make here I think
is that 538 Nate silver have been known
as the you know the end-all be-all
which the generic ballot is really that
that part of the data that you really
want to watch the problem is here
that the Republicans have worked really
hard to stuff in a ton of [ __ ]
numbers into the aggregate
and that's affecting that generic ballot
because what they're trying to do is
convince not they're not trying to
convince you right and what I mean by
you is like the pro-democracy voter
I mean maybe they're trying to suppress
your vote by making you think that
Republicans are going to win it no
matter what so you'll just stay at home
I actually believe that motivates you
more now because after 2020 it shows
that hey if we all band together and go
vote against these [ __ ] fascists we
can get them the [ __ ] out of here
just like we sent the Cheeto dust Cuban
on her packing now tomorrow Lago now he
has a shut his [ __ ] mouth like he
should have but we sent him packing
but I believe that 538 is going off the
numbers that they have and I'm not an
eight silver fan by any stretch of the
matter [ __ ] Nate silver [ __ ] him
honestly he's a [ __ ] he's [ __ ] that guy
because all they want to do all they
want to do is be correct
that's all they want to do
and these poles and I've been saying
this for months and months and months
these polls are [ __ ] [ __ ] they're
way off we saw that in the primary we
saw that in the in the vote on the
referendum in Kansas it was way off in
in New York's 19th in the Alaska race
they were way the [ __ ] off
so Don't Preach to me about how the
numbers are the numbers sure the numbers
are the numbers but if you make up the
[ __ ] numbers
if you juice the numbers and then put
them in the aggregate the aggregate is
Juiced
it's [ __ ] Juiced
and it's Juiced for this narrative that
Republicans were supposed to win and
then they lost they are preparing to
lose folks
that's what they're doing
and it's all in this this idea of
election denial because they really
truly want another January 6th
they want more violence they want more
people showing up at Democrats residents
with hammers they want that that's why
they're [ __ ] making so light of this
the stoking of stochastic terrorism is
[ __ ] real
and they're [ __ ] dangerous that is
why we must protect our democracy that
is why we must lean into it they're
terrified of democracy I showed you a
clip yesterday of that [ __ ] Nazi
Charlie Kirk
who by the way paid for how many buses
I watched the uh the the documentary
last night and called God forbid about
Jerry Falwell and his sexcapades his
hypocritical sex campaigns
I watched that documentary and they talk
about Charlie Kirk because Charlie Kirk
is up in partner with Jerry Falwell
they're partners
in an organization that does nothing but
[ __ ] Stoke violence in this country
by bussing people to the January 6th
Insurrection and having them march on
the Capitol and try to steal our
government
so yeah yeah I understand that the
numbers say what they say but there's a
reason why they're saying what they say
they're [ __ ] [ __ ] they're
[ __ ]
and they're intentionally making it
[ __ ] so they have the narrative that
hey all the polls said even Nate silver
said we were supposed to win
we should not concede because I would
bet any election that Republicans lose
they're not going to concede
but any election they win on the same
exact ballot they're going to be excited
that they won
just like in 2020 they're just setting
up a narrative folks that's all they're
doing
it's we are at the intersection of
WrestleMania and real life
do you ever watch the WWE maybe way back
in the old days
too when they used to do the
dramatization and they used to you know
that what they they'd have like a a fake
hospital room set up where someone would
be in the hospital bed and they'd have
their legs broken from last week which
the injuries are real in wrestling the
injuries are real
the the fake hospital rooms and all the
the drama and [ __ ] that's all made up
and they don't make it up on the Fly
well some of it may be but they don't
make a lot of it up on the Fly they're
planning on what the storyline's gonna
be
you see you see how that works they're
planning on what the storyline is going
to be
and they get the audience to play and do
that storyline they get them to play and
do it and Mike you're right that is why
they're using 538 and 8 silver
they're using them as the audience
to play into their narrative
now if Nate silver and 538 had any kind
of [ __ ] credibility they would be out
yelling and screaming hey these are the
numbers but this looks [ __ ] fishy as
[ __ ] these polls are [ __ ] weird
we can't hardly trust these are the
numbers but we can't hardly trust these
numbers
but they're not
because 538 and Nate silver they pedal
in being correct
and they want to be correct so they
follow the numbers that's why the media
is saying the Republicans are going to
win because that's what the that's what
the polls are saying all these
right-wing manga Republican polls are
saying that they're gonna win why would
they create a poll that said they're
going to lose have you ever met one of
these [ __ ] have you ever met
one of these Maga snowflakes get the
[ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
okay
so let's go to um
someone who absolutely schools the manga
Republicans this is Tim Ryan I don't
know if you've seen we played several
clips of Tim Ryan absolutely destroying
Maga Republicans
Tim Ryan is not a a Bourgeois liberal
Coastal Elite Democrat right
he's a union guy from Ohio
Rust Belt Midwest type guy
roll your sleeves up throw some fist
type guy right
he's not scared to talk [ __ ] on China he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he doesn't care
about offending people even [ __ ] the
left he doesn't give a [ __ ] he only
cares about one [ __ ] thing and
one [ __ ] thing only how to win
elections in Ohio so he can set policy
for us got it I understand it is most
important that Tim Ryan focuses on
winning Ohio so that way he can set
policy if he doesn't win the election in
Ohio he cannot set policy but this type
of democrat this brand of democrat is
coming back in full force I believe
that's why our audience is gaining such
ground
this this [ __ ]
this little weak ass liberal thing is
not is we are not that brand anymore
that is not us Liberals are not weak
Liberals are the strength of democracy
the strength around the world the
strength for equality and equity for
everyone making sure that people are
delivered their [ __ ] Liberty
liberal Liberty got it
Tim Ryan leans straight into it now he's
at a Fox News town hall and they
interviewed JD Vance I know before him
or after him but this clip is most
important and because the Fox News hosts
are asking him questions about January
6th Insurrection and he starts to talk
about it he doesn't back down from his
[ __ ] position
and he takes the crown from booing
booing at him to cheering for what he
says
now this is the reason why I say that I
am welcomed the hate Watchers here
that is why I say this is because what
Tim Ryan does in this clip watch
they storm the capital on January 6th
they beat up 140 police officers killed
killed one okay they killed what they
killed one
[Applause]
we all we all we all watch we all watch
the we all watch the video we all watch
a video and I okay
let him finish please and I work I'm
happy to have this conversation I'm not
afraid to have this conversation these
are the conversations we need to have in
this country I welcome you guys let's
just be respectful but I'm not afraid to
stand here and defend my position
and watch him defend his position and
watch what happens when he shows his
position
these people can't argue with his
position once they hear it that's why
they try to drown us out that's why they
come after people like me that's why
they come after other commentators
that's why they come after other
politicians who are willing to [ __ ]
speak out
that's why they [ __ ] hate Liz Cheney
Liz Chaney has endorsed Tim Ryan
not because Liz Cheney loves Tim Ryan or
she's some somehow on the ideological
scale equal to Tim Ryan she's not even
close she just knows the danger of JD
Vance
the guy who called Trump America's
Hitler and now he's endorsed by him and
gonna rubber stamp his agenda
now listen how Tim Ryan goes from what
you just saw to defending his position
and what the crown does
um on January 6th 140 kept I I sit on
the subcommittee that funds the Capitol
Police
these are my friends 140 of them got
hurt and some of them still can't go
back to work because they were beat up
with lead pipes they were sprayed with
pepper spray they were beaten with
flagpoles okay they were trying to
overthrow the government they were
trying to stop the peaceful transition
of the government what else were they
doing there are they gonna kill Mike
Pence right you want to kill Nancy
Pelosi now somebody's beating up Nancy
Pelosi's husband with a hammer
JD Vance raised money for the
insurrectionist he made several social
media posts to raise money for them now
again I don't care what your politics
are but Americans should say no we have
to say no to that we're going to try to
get as many questions
so there you have it
there you have it he turns an audience
from booing him and calling him a liar
to applauding him
did he do anything really special there
I mean other than he just stood his
ground told the [ __ ] truth pointed
out the fact that hey the reason why
Paul Pelosi's brains got bashed in with
a hammer the reason why is because you
people are still believing [ __ ] lies
about January 6th
I bet he turned some people in that room
maybe not a lot maybe one maybe two
took the off ramp and will continue to
take the off-ramp maybe a few more
looked at the off ramp and went you know
what that doesn't look too shabby maybe
I should take that off ramp I really I
really don't want to be tied in with the
with the Maga Hammer assassin
right
I believe that he possibly could have in
that moment
it's really unclear whether we will see
that or not
but I'm telling you that's the most
important part some people are saying
they can't hear the clips I'll try to
turn them up some of these clips when I
get them online the the the the volume
just isn't um very big let's see what
else do we have oh I want to show you
this everyone's been sending me these
things and I appreciate this I want you
to keep going
um Margie one of our great moderators
thank you Margie are you I don't know if
you're
um in the chat today are great
moderators MJ Margie
Margie sent me this picture
excuse me and Robin we got three
moderators here Robin MJ and Margie
great moderators give them love at
Robin's giving love right now
um I think she's loving this this this
this sticker here
Margie went and voted and she that
people been sending me they're um
they're voted stickers so that is very
encouraging please early vote if you can
get out there an early Vote or make a
plan to vote the day of the election
um Robin is here I think MJ's here too
do we have Margie with us today
not always there there's MJ so give give
the moderators love here uh Robin Margie
and MJ here in the YouTube chat and
again if you're not oh there she is she
says I'm here
hello everyone hello hello hello give
the moderators some love in the chat you
guys are the best audience in the world
we have the best moderators here don't
you agree uh so send me send me your
your I voted sticker
send it to me show it to the world that
you voted it is important that is great
encouragement I know I know it doesn't
feel like that is something
um that is important but it is super
important when people see that people
are willing to say yes I voted and I'm
proud I voted that is a very important
thing
it's one of the most important things
it's a third party endorsement for a
vote so not only go vote but also make
sure you're finding those three people
to encourage right three people to
encourage to vote and make sure those
three people find three people and once
you find those three people
once you find those three people
absolutely find another three
um here is another clip from the uh the
Ryan
um
uh Town Hall in Ohio is talking about
legalizing marijuana
this I mean again I don't understand why
people don't understand this I was
talking to someone the other day uh one
of the people I was encouraging to vote
um
and they were I asked him and I asked
them a simple question and you can ask
people this question too that's part of
the uh the process of encouragement to
vote
you say this
what is the most important issue that
politicians are going to set policy for
in your mind what is the one issue the
one thing and this person told me
that the decriminalization of marijuana
was very important to them that's the
most important issue
that was what they that was the issue
that was most important to them at this
moment in history now you know
regardless of maybe how insignificant or
significant it may be I believe it's
actually very significant in our society
to recognize that non-violent possession
of marijuana for us to spend our time
money and energy on this stuff is
ridiculous it's absolutely stupid
most people in this country know how
ridiculous it is that alcohol is much
more dangerous than most drugs out there
alcohol is a drug and alcohol is way
more dangerous of a drug than most
others I don't smoke marijuana
medically or otherwise
now there is on the ballot here in
Missouri
there is the decriminalization of
marijuana there's going to be
recreational marijuana here in here in
Missouri it's going to be on the ballot
I'm going to go vote for that
I'm gonna mark my vote for that
because I believe it's ridiculous that
we would bang up anyone in court over
the possession of a little bag of weed
or a joint it's really stupid stuff
really dumb stuff
alcohol is much more dangerous and I
actually prefer I prefer the drug
alcohol over marijuana
maybe it's because I just you know
haven't experienced and we talked about
this on the show with Gabe Sanchez he
has a lot more experience
with THC than I do and and the one
reason why is that that I haven't
participated in much in my life
with smoking marijuana is because I'm a
former cigarette smoker
I'm a former cigarette smoker some
someone says here let's see uh uh
um uh
Aaron YouTube says I'll smoke weed for
you that you smoke it for me because I
can't smoke weed I'm a former cigarette
smoker I had this experience the other
day I actually woke up from a bad dream
and the only reason why I was bad dream
is because I was smoking cigarettes in
it I haven't smoked cigarettes and Jesus
uh over 10 years probably almost 12
years since it's been since I smoked
cigarettes and I still when I dream
about myself and remember those dreams I
am still smoking cigarettes so I can't
smoke anything I feel like it would give
me this urge to continue to smoke
cigarettes and I believe that cigarettes
are probably a worse drug
then a lot of drugs out there even more
than alcohol
anyways besides the point
enough about enough about me now
this clip here and I know it might be
tough on the volume I'm going to try to
turn it up but this clip here they're
asking him about
legalizing marijuana on a federal level
and so let's
uh someone says bake some brownies yeah
I'm not against I'm I wouldn't be
against Edibles I guess I mean I
wouldn't be against edibles
I just you know again I I I
drink alcohol so I wouldn't be against
Edibles right I wouldn't be against
maybe that's a thing they should have
it's like a like a marijuana beer I
don't know do they have that or like a
like a white call White claw marijuana
I don't know I don't know how this [ __ ]
works you people know better than I do
but here's the thing I would definitely
definitely try Edibles in a controlled
situation because I've never done it
before anyways let's go to the clip of
Paul Ryan or excuse me Tim Ryan Jesus
Christ we're at the bottom of the second
hour it's been an hour and a half my
brain is melting now that I'm I'm
talking about uh marijuana here we go
let's watch Mr Ryan talk about marijuana
from in prison and a lot of people fall
into that non-violent category including
drug traffickers including drug
possession including people who
distribute child pornography so all
those people should be let out well what
I'm talking about here is marijuana
crimes I think we need to legalize
marijuana I think well you said
unviolent criminals out sure I'm sorry
you you said all non-violent criminals I
think the focus is marijuana crimes in
my mind right we spend this is this may
be the stupidest expenditure of federal
federal money in in public taxpayer
money in the history of our country you
get caught with marijuana then you end
up in prison and and that is insane for
us we should take we should tax the
marijuana and we should put it into
addiction treatment we should use it to
keep Fentanyl and these hardcore drugs
out of our country out of our society we
should invest in the shop class we
should invest into early childhood
education there's so many better ways to
spend this money than locking somebody
up for marijuana crimes and especially
when
when white and black people use
marijuana equally black people are six
times more likely to go to prison like
that's an unfair system I'm sorry it
just doesn't make any sense to me
so there you have it Tim Ryan telling us
about marijuana and again it's not in
rocket science it's not something that
the American people don't want which is
to decriminalize this this a plant a
plant there's so much history behind it
and again we could argue on and on and
on and on why
but it's the same thing with most
Americans wanting most things policy set
into place
but look this might be a starting point
for someone what I mean by that is just
like my experience with the person I
encourage to go vote because here's what
I said to that person
I said look
you're gonna go vote in Missouri
for the recreational marijuana
referendum they said yes absolutely I
wanted to be recreational here in
Missouri I said who are you going to
vote for for Senator
probably Eric Schmidt I'm a republican I
said now now let's think about this
let's think there's three for a second
so you're gonna vote to make sure that
recreational marijuana
is is legal here in Missouri but you're
gonna make a vote to make sure
that in the Senate the United States
Senate when a bill comes to the United
States Senate that you're going to send
a vote there to make sure to criminalize
to keep marijuana on the schedule one
you understand that you're doing two
different things
and I'm not here to tell you what to
believe or what not to believe but
you're telling me what you believe is
that marijuana should be decriminalized
then you should vote
for Democrats if that is your number one
issue if that is an issue at the top of
your list maybe in your top two or three
then you should be voting Democrat
because folks I asked that same person I
said do you know why the Republicans are
against
the decriminalization of marijuana
you know why
he couldn't wait he went in a roundabout
way I said yeah yeah that you know I I
get the the the old tropes and stuff
the reason why Republicans
in this time in 2022 let me tell you why
they are against
the decriminalization of marijuana on a
federal level because the Democrats are
for it
at simple you can go back and look at
all the history you can give me a you
know a [ __ ] whole dictionary a whole
stack of Statistics all this [ __ ]
that they say about Law and Order and
all that [ __ ] it's all [ __ ] all of
it it's all nonsense they don't believe
a single [ __ ] word of that [ __ ]
they're saying the only reason why
they're against the decriminalization on
a federal level of marijuana or in
states is because Democrats are for it
just go watch [ __ ] Laurie Ingram on
Fox News have Reefer Madness oh my God
she's terrified it sounds like I don't
know all the [ __ ] that they say
about people in bathrooms or transgender
people are the LGBT community or drag
shows it's the same [ __ ] same
nonsense they follow the same [ __ ]
steps same [ __ ] fear tactics
fear-mongering
it's because
Democrats are for decriminalizing
marijuana that's there for that
the entirety of the protemocracy
apparatus which right now is the
Democratic party in this country because
there's not a single [ __ ] thread of
pro-democracy inside the Republican
party if there is they're [ __ ] ousted
and they got to go [ __ ] support
Democrats like Liz Cheney is supporting
Tim Ryan in Ohio
pluck your head out of your ass
and realize that the reason why
Republicans have no good ideas is
because they have to be against all
Democrats ideas
they can't be for any of them even the
good ones like Democrats have some
shitty ideas
oh [ __ ] yeah Democrats have some shitty
ideas don't don't get it twisted they
have shitty ideas
sure of course I I you know I'll I'll we
can sit and argue that all day long
after this election
but the reason why Republicans it seems
like they have no ideas
is because they have to be against every
idea that the Democrats have every
[ __ ] last one of them
even the [ __ ] good ones they can't be
for a good idea it just can't happen
and it knew
um same thing on energy policy there's
another video of that but I do want to
show you this um speaking of the January
6th Insurrection uh Tim Ryan brought up
the officers being beaten here is um
and and speaking of election deniers in
Kerry Lake earlier here is Officer
Fatone he was the one of the officers
beaten brutally beaten nearly to an inch
of his life the day of the Insurrection
um here he is talking about Carrie Lake
listen to what he has to say
yeah no I mean I've gotten to know
Mississippi pretty well and
um I thought that was a powerful ad
um
I mean she's out there I think trying to
uh do what all of us are trying to do
here which is bring accountability for
January 6th and um
you know I also support the fact that
Carrie Lake's piece of [ __ ] so
um I'm glad she did that ad no one is
gonna say that you haven't put it all
out on the line in the bluntest terms
yeah he believes Gary lake is a piece of
[ __ ] I don't know what do you think I'm
for it I'm for it
oh here here we go and we got fake Gabe
in the chat here
um so I got I gotta I gotta I gotta put
him put him in his place here bear with
me for a second he said see January 6
cannot fill up your gas tank or feed
your family
hey fake Gabe what do you think is going
to happen to gas prices and inflation
when the fascists take over and destroy
your democracy
you think you think you think they're
not going to try to take over
corporations you think they're not going
to encourage corporations once they take
them over to gouge you
you really are stupid I mean I know we
went over this over and over and over
again about inflation and how it works
and what the effects are and I know I
know you wish that Joe Biden had a
gasoline button on his [ __ ] desk
the gas prices are going down
and the reason why is because the
president United States is using the
power that he actually has with fuel
by releasing the oil reserves that our
country has which I don't think is
always the best option
but it's the option that he's got in his
hand if there's a gasoline button he has
the ability to flood the market that's
the option that he has is to flood the
market with Reserve oil now the reason
why he has to do that fake Gabe is
because your buddy Putin and your your
TR and Trump's Buddies the Saudis OPEC
has stopped production
which has increased the price of fuel
your price of fuel you [ __ ] idiot so
when you decide that you're gonna blame
the [ __ ] people
that are causing some of the corporate
greed and the corporate inflation the
fake [ __ ] inflation There's real
inflation don't get me wrong
but when you when you start to blame
OPEC which this country's starting to do
that's what I believe is showing up in
this early vote
when you start blaming the actual cause
of the problem which is when OPEC stops
the production because they don't like
the price they don't like the price
dumping you [ __ ] bonehead maybe maybe
just maybe
OPEC will start to say well maybe we
don't have a lot of allies
in America maybe Putin will not believe
that the Maga supporters are on his side
you are Putin's puppet dummy when you
come in the comments and you type out
[ __ ] like this this comment right here
this is exactly what Vladimir Putin
wants your dumbass to do
in our democracy spread stupid [ __ ]
statements like this
and I'm not afraid to point them out and
I'm not afraid to tell you where the
[ __ ] to stick your statement right
straight up Putin's ass
that's what you don't realize you stupid
[ __ ] is that when you say [ __ ] like this
about the price of gas number one it
makes you look really [ __ ] dumb
because it just clearly you do not
understand now fuel prices work
capitalism or anything else
but when when you when you don't
understand that the reason why we still
have a democracy today
is because
officers like the one we just saw on TV
calling Carrie Lake a [ __ ] fascist
and a piece of [ __ ]
that's the reason why you still have
your way of life right now
because fake Gabe I don't know if you
know this or not
but if you really truly get what you
want
if you truly really get what you want
which is that white supremacy all across
the land trumps the king Putin's his
boss
and you think you're safe you are a
stupid [ __ ] you are dumb as dog [ __ ] the
minute because you're one of you're one
of the [ __ ] you're one of the Trump
copy machines out there right so you're
one you're one of the people spreading
the information that they want you to
spread the minute you stop spreading
that information you're done son you're
one of the first ones to go
you're one of the first you're you're an
absolute dissident
you're an absolute dissident
you don't even know it
I'm not a distant I believe in democracy
I believe in the people I believe our
voices can be collectively heard
I don't dissent against anyone or
anything
besides fascist I will not tolerate
fascism no [ __ ] way no [ __ ] how
because it leads us down a road where
you my friend you are at risk of the
regime
so
here you go there's your fake Gabe for
today I'm sure he'll say more dumb [ __ ]
here and of course he yeah here we go
here here see here we go uh liberal
fascist
the the liberal fascist
look you fake Gabe
what you need to do is you need to dust
off the [ __ ] dictionary or use that
[ __ ] Google machine you got your
hands that you're using the comment
in the chat here on Facebook
is go look up the definitions of the
words liberal and fascist go look those
words up and just I want you to know the
definition of those two words
and when you figure out the definition
of those two [ __ ] words then come
back here
and we might talk about me being a
liberal fascist you really are a [ __ ]
bonehead now okay let's see what else
oh boy oh I know what we can do let's do
this
um Gabe Sanchez did it what was that oh
see if we can get this um going here
sorry
that's an ad okay so
um Gabe Sanchez did a what was that on
the Trump rally so let's see if we can
play oh no that's not what we want
it is
I'm trying I'm trying here uh usually he
grabs these links for me let's play the
um uh we're at we're we're 41 minutes
into the second hour so I think we'll
have time to play this here
um I think why I'm trying to play this
so we'll play Gabe Sanchez
um
doing what was that on the Trump rally
see if I can get the volumes correct
here that way you guys can hear it uh
here we go here's Gabe Sanchez
with uh what was that on the tiny Crown
in a Tiny Town let's listen hey everyone
and welcome back to what was that with
Gabe Sanchez Trump's recent rally in
Texas had all the fixings for a good
time the orange Carnival Barker
complained about the January 6th
committee subpoena he wants to imprison
journalists and his cultiven did their
weird hail Trump Q Anon salute
[Music]
foreign
before I dig into Trump's traveling
clown circus at the regional fairgrounds
in Robstown Texas I want to take a
moment to acknowledge the backup
performers first up we have Trump's
incompetent and racist attorney and hope
hick stand in Alina Haba Hicks by the
way just interviewed with the January 6
committee which
is not a great sign for Trump anyway
here's Elena Haba at the rally that's
why I'm here we got to get out and vote
so that we don't have a dual system of
justice as you know and hi guys over
there you're not allowed to be political
in the courtroom you have to apply a lot
of fact and I have seen it firsthand it
is very corrupt let me get this straight
in order to fight a justice system that
is too political Alina have a went to a
political event with a politician
yeah that makes zero sense and what
better way to travel to a political
event than fly in a trump farts one
Trump forced one God I keep saying farts
not to be confused with the new Trump
force one that he asked his supporters
to help pay for after his current one
experienced engine trouble here's Elena
Habbo with Trump on his plane she looks
like she's trying to replace his wife
Ivanka I mean Melania also what is going
on with Trump's face you you know what
I don't even want to know what happened
moments before this photo was taken
anyway next up on America's not talented
we have Mike Lindell performing his act
of will anybody take me seriously if you
get a mail-in voter whatever mail-in
ballot just bring it with you to make
sure if they tell you oh you already
voted say no I did and you go to your
local sheriff the sheriffs are going to
bring sheriffs and judges I believe are
going to bring this country back I swear
this guy only has two settings it's
either hawk and crappy pillows or
spreading election conspiracy theories
there is no in between I just they just
gave me a little badge Brian I love it
I'm I'm semi-official what is with these
Republicans thinking a fake badge makes
them cops seriously Mike Lindell is as
much a cop as Herschel Walker these are
the same people that supposedly backed
the blue but then gaslit Capital police
about January 6th anyway let's get back
to Trump's fascist rally on the county
fairgrounds at least this one had grass
on it previously in Arizona Trump held a
rally and what seemed to be a sand later
box no seriously Kerry Lake the
gubernatorial candidate of Arizona was
vacuuming a cheap red carpet and front
of a wish.com version of the
presidential seal oh and the reason
Trump has to hold his rallies outside is
because he's notorious for not paying
for them he still owes the city of El
Paso Texas over five hundred thousand
dollars and as of right now Trump still
owes roughly 2 million dollars to
various cities but let's jump into the
rally you know in this country they leak
all over the place even on the Supreme
Court by the way you have to find the
leaker of the Supreme you have to find
the liquor wow okay this is gonna be
interesting you take the writer and or
the publisher of the paper a certain
Paper it you know and you say who is the
leaker National Security
and they say we're not going to tell you
they say it's okay you're going to jail
the guy who stole classified documents
is now threatening journalists who
exercise Free Press rights with
imprisonment and when this person
realizes that he is going to be
the Bride of another prisoner very
shortly Donald Trump a former president
is joking about rape as a form of
punishment this right here is the best
the Republican party has to offer but we
shouldn't be surprised Trump hates
anyone in the Press who doesn't
regurgitate his lies and if you remember
back in 2015 he mocked a disabled
reporter you got to see this guy oh I
don't know what I said uh I don't
remember if you remember what I've said
in the past when you go against trumpism
you are now An Enemy of the State this
is what the Republican party is fascists
and speaking of Journalism Trump now
claims he's going to sue the Pulitzer
organization over the Russia election
interference coverage so you have
reporters from The Washington Post the
New York Times that got Pulitzer prizes
and they reported the exact wrong thing
so within the next two weeks we're suing
the Pulitzer organization to have those
prizes taken back oh he's going to sue
them in two weeks yeah that's a load of
crap I mean I'm still waiting for
Trump's healthcare plan that he said
will come out in two weeks now this is
when the rally entered Jim Jones star
territory and uh honestly it was earlier
than I expected while Trump was speaking
the crowd started singing the National
Anthem here see for yourself the people
went down there and you could have had
over a million people
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and Trump just stands there without
saying anything because well he doesn't
know the words and this is not his first
offense Trump the great Patriot that
they claim that he is has always seemed
confused during the anthem like this one
time in 2018.
foreign
[Applause]
Trump's speech he started whining about
the January 6 committee serving him a
subpoena to testify they never talk
about and they sent me a subpoena the
other day this should not be a big deal
if you're innocent and have nothing to
hide according to Trump's attorney Alina
Haba Trump has no issue being deposed he
um has no issue being deposed even
though the left-wing media would like to
pretend that he does despite what Alina
habit says there is no way that Trump
agrees to testify and if he does he will
absolutely plead the fifth and that's
because Trump tried to rig the 2020
election and overthrow the government on
January 6 to remain in power but back to
the rally face crooked people and the
only thing they don't invest that they
don't want to do investigate the only
thing they don't want to do they won't
investigate was the corruption that took
place in that election which was massive
if only there was a committee to I don't
know investigate the January 6
Insurrection in the events leading up to
it after the election I've covered this
before in past episodes of this show but
I'll just say it again Trump's own
attorney general bill bar said claims of
widespread voter fraud were [ __ ] and
because it's Trump he has to blame
someone and the facts are all there we
have so many for every single swing
state you take a look and most of the
people in this audience know it because
you know a lot more and these people
back there they don't want to cover it
of course no one wants to cover it
they're all in billion dollar lawsuits
because of it and we know the Trump
Administration and right-wing media knew
they were lying because the CEO of
dominion explained it to Anderson Cooper
on 60 Minutes you as a company told them
specifically repeatedly we told them we
told them in real time others told them
government officials told them partisan
government officials told them people
inside uh the Trump Administration told
them local election officials on both
sides of the aisle told them this is not
a matter of not knowing the truth they
knew the truth anyway
foreign
there was an ad in the middle of it hang
on a second let me see if I can get past
the head
we don't want any ads hang on hang on
hang on just a minute here we go
that's what happens
we transitioned into talking about
Mar-A-Lago they have found
one thing I will say they found that I
like you am a great Patriot that's what
they found wait what was that they found
that I like you am a great Patriot
correct me if I'm wrong but I'm pretty
sure Patriots don't dabble in treason in
Espionage Trump literally had highly
sensitive intelligence regarding China
and Iran Trump has absolutely no reason
to have any of that stuff at Mar-A-Lago
or anywhere else and then in a
predictable fashion Trump tried to pull
a what about ISM with previous
presidents have you seen the last five
or six presidents what they did they
took it they're in Chinese laundries
they're stored they're in storage houses
where the windows and doors are broken
look I'll make this one simple Trump is
lying and stupid Also if anyone can make
sense of this next rant please translate
it for me and then contact Trump's
doctor sir we have boxes store to the
storage remote where are they oh well
they haven't been we haven't seen them
for a while Mike have those boxes where
are they right now and since the rally
took place in Texas some local
politicians made their way to to the
stage Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton
who has been under federal investigation
for the last seven years was also at the
rally and set a record for the number of
times someone could kiss Trump's ass in
less than a minute how does this
President draw a crowd year after year
thousands of people maybe it's he's a
great speaker is it because he's a great
businessman maybe it's because you're a
great golfer he's done more for the
American people than any president in
our lifetime Ken Paxton knows that Trump
is not the President right like he
understands that Trump just can't give
him a pardon for what he's being
investigated for and then like clockwork
Trump spoke over the infamous Q Anon
theme song for nearly 10 minutes
10 minutes
I'm sorry I had to stop it I couldn't
sit through that again and if you
noticed as soon as the song Started
fingers started going up just like the
Nazi finger salute at the Trump rally in
Ohio and deep down these insane rallies
have really just become a way for Trump
to publicly admit to crimes and play the
victim and then use that to grift money
from his cult and what Trump doesn't
want to support us to know is that his
fundraising packs are losing money
specifically a net loss of around 13
million dollars over the last three
months oh looks like the Trump train is
running on empty oh well I'm Gabe
Sanchez and this has been what was that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so there you have it Gabe Sanchez with
what was that on the Trump rally
look
we get word uh that there was a sealed
hearing with a federal judge about the
documents case
um that case
was supposed to go Trump that that that
sealed meeting was supposed to go
Trump's way right it was supposed to go
the Cheeto Dusky and Honor's way the
problem is is he had an immediate freak
out and he freaked out on fraud social
over and over and over again it was
actually kind of pathetic and the reason
why is because it didn't go his way he
literally thought I believe in that
sealed hearing with the documents
that the judge was going to drop any
investigation and just allow him to walk
free
and that is not what happened the
opposite of that happened
this guy is in Greek Peril great legal
peril this is why they're so they're so
hell-bent on denying elections that's
why they want Kerry Lake to be the
governor of Arizona
it's so important that she be the
governor of Arizona because if she's the
governor of Arizona she will be the
governor of Arizona in 2024.
and she is all but said she will
absolutely 100 percent not certify a
result that has that is not what she
wants
we know that the current governor Ducey
in Arizona Trump called him
called him while he was signing
the legislator certification of their
State's vote of their electoral vote for
president United States
Trump was calling him
begging
begging to believe his lies begging to
perpetuate
Maga fascism in this country to overturn
our democracy that is what they want
they will not stop until they get it
it is a thing that they are going to
continue to do and that is why they want
Kerry Lake
in power
in Arizona
so she can just with a stroke of a pen
say nope
yeah I don't like those results they
aren't the results I need and I want
so we'll take them away
and delude the voters
into believing
like what the dumb [ __ ] here manga the
manga caught on camera this guy
the hammer Maga assassin
they want to continue to dilute these
people
they are relying on these people to save
them
I believe that the Maga Republicans have
come to terms with that they're not
going to probably gain the Senate not a
thing they're more than likely not going
to get the house I believe they are not
even going to come close to getting the
house to be quite honest
because their original goal was to
get the house and maybe use hammers to
make Donald Trump the president of the
United States by making him the speaker
and then again using uh hammer assassins
to make him the president of the United
States that is a that is a thing that
could happen they're deluded it's
delusional I know it sounds crazy
but folks we live in a crazy timeline
it's crazy times
and we must take drastic measures
and what I mean by that is you must lean
into your democracy more than you ever
had before
now is the time to engage
talk to your neighbors your family your
friends ask them ask them what the most
important issue is to them
you have the ammunition of how to handle
these folks
you have it I know you do you come here
every single weekday Monday through
Friday for two full hours to watch this
show to know what ammunition you need
to know what sunlight you need to shine
to disinfect their delusion
you have it it's those tools are at your
disposal that's what I do every single
day
that is literally my goal I know we do
it in a fun way we make you laugh
sometimes it's cathartic
you like to see me yelling screaming to
a microphone maybe the stuff that you
want to yell and scream and do a
microphone yourself I get it
but more than anything I am arming you
with the ability to go out there and
absolutely absolutely shine
the light of disinfectant
on folks around you
on their delusion like this dumb
[ __ ]
who decided it was a good idea to try to
go kidnap the speaker of the house and
Bash her husband's brains in with a
hammer
now he's going to go to prison for the
rest of his life
he won't see the line of day for
probably 40 50 years
this guy's gonna go away for a long time
because he's not just going to get get
State charges he's going to get federal
charges now they'll he'll serve those
things consecutively
but he's going to serve a long sentence
he's going to be locked up for a long
time
but this is what Kerry Lake this is what
Donald Trump this is what Steve Bannon
this is the misinformation that they
want
and it is up to you to save your
democracy I know I know it's a lot see
that is the thing about being liberals
in a liberal democracy
it's being liberals in the liberal
democracy it is you that have to do the
work to protect it
if if you don't want to protect your
government if you don't want to protect
the system and the lifestyle that you
have then you're probably an
authoritarian if you expect someone else
to do it for you
if you expect someone else to tell you
what to think what to do where to go how
to believe what God to worship or
whether you worship God or at all
to tell you what medical procedures you
can have what books you should read
what speech you should be able to say
what truth you can speak what history
you can know
if you want a a certain individual to
tell you that stuff you're a cultist
you're an authoritarian you're a fascist
but here in the liberal USA in this
liberal democracy that we have a
constitutional republic
democracy is difficult
it's hard
it's not weak
strong that's the reason why
the reason why our democracy is so
strong and the reason why it didn't fall
to these [ __ ] nincompoop Nazis
because liberalism isn't weak
it's about Freedom rights
Liberty
and making those rights and those
freedoms that we Grant through our
constitution
to everyone in this country every single
person who's here rather they're a
citizen rather they're here on some kind
of immigration status
rather they're a migrant-seeking refuge
or or they came here
without any kind of legal status they
are here they have those rights
and we strive to progress to equality
and equity for every single person all
of them
no matter race
Creed religion
sex gender sexual orientation
no matter what
that is the hard work of a liberal
democracy and that is why you see these
Mega cultists
these domestic terrorists
turning towards authoritarianism
because they're weak
they're weak they're scared and they're
snowflakes
so do not let up
lean all the way the [ __ ] in now is the
time we are less than a week away from
you the voter
saving our democracy our constitutional
republic
Now's the Time
everybody thanks for joining me today on
the Tony Michaels podcast as you do
every single weekday Monday through
Friday two full hours noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch
until tomorrow I love you until tomorrow
Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon